i think 10 years from now it could be
the case that you see unicorns with one
person right so you think that we will
potentially we will have
billion dollar companies created with
only one employee absolutely
that is
wild i mean like if you look at crypto
right yep
bitcoin it was a i mean you had a set of
people but the initial idea was created
by one individual probably satoshi
nakamoto who i think was elo musk but
yeah do you think elon musk is satoshi
yeah
yeah yeah
why do you think that elon musk is
satoshi um there are a bunch of clues
why
he's satoshi nakamoto so for example the
code base uh was
like is written in c plus plus which is
this programming language and it's
basically a block
uh and that that's usually how elon elon
programs his stuff also the way uh
he he used to type his sentences in in
this uh forum
uh there were like double spaces between
you know one sentence and another that's
how elon musk writes
uh the way he talks satoshi nakamoto
writes in the forum he talks about you
know uh
porn guys in the forum and then you have
pito guys you know there are a bunch of
clues that point out to the fact that
you know elon musk uh satoshi nakamoto
he has been thinking about money for you
know a long long time paypal the
original idea was to create
like money
to the world to replace you know
these banks and so hold on a second
i disagree with you that elon is satoshi
but let's go down this path and say yeah
uh if elon was satoshi yeah
would they just put them in jail like
would it just be like they just play man
we got to stop this guy that's why he
can't say he's satoshi nakamoto right
you think so yeah
like for the longest time i thought okay
elon musk is going to be the richest man
alive and then it's going to be satoshi
nakamoto right because the people would
have an absolute meltdown
if it came out that elon was satoshi but
both good meltdown and badminton yeah
there's people in the bitcoin community
who would not
be super ecstatic about it there's
people outside the bitcoin community who
would uh be ecstatic about like it would
just be mass chaos i know uh
and i i think he will never say that
he's satoshi nakamoto i don't think he
you has a self-discipline from looking
from the outside i think that somebody
would say something stupid to him and he
would just
he's underrated i think people
don't realize how smart he is
um one of the things like he he he talks
a lot of in twitter because that
drives engagement yes he knows that that
drives engagement that's why he's so
funny
on twitter right
like creating spacex like
it's amazing he created rockets that
lend themselves in their own fit right
he's he's creating self-driving cars
this guy is nuts this guy is completely
nuts
people like underrate him he's like he's
steve jobs on steroids yep um
anyway
satoshi nakamoto has a really
strong incentive to take out his coins
because he's going to be the richest man
alive
or woman or whatever
elo musk is already the richest man
alive right he doesn't think he wouldn't
touch the coins because he doesn't need
him yeah exactly if it was some random
guy right
he has a strong incentive to take out
the coins
but if you're already the richest man
alive
like taking out the coins you're you're
still gonna be the richest man in life
so it doesn't matter
hey you did you like this video great
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time